hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back what's behind you
[Applause]
nothing probably nothing anyway we're
starting off with a game called police
force we're going to the Barker
residence if you could stop them and set
some
siren they'll be wonderful thank you
thank you for this
Thank You 1031 1988 case suspects Adam
Barker 48 year old Caucasian male case
hostages Margaret Barker and Mary Beth
Barker neighbors have called the
domestic disturbance on the Barker
household Adam Barker is known marker
marker Barker Barker Barker and embark
or is known avatar with his family and
has also recently been undergoing
psychiatric treatment the 911 caller
reported hearing screaming and believes
Adam may be dangerous to his family
proceed with caution
Adam Barker is assumed I was not done
reading up an atom marker oh hello wast
unholstered whoa whoa whoa mama
you can only interact when the gun is
holstered all right well ooh
squeaky peaky all right maggots inside
my brain made me go insane my expert
analysis is that he's got maggots in his
brain and they made him go insane that's
my expert analysis who do I need to
shoot who do I need to give the old Boom
Bang II - oh god you're dead you're
already dead that scared me way more
than it should have was excuse me you're
lucky I didn't have my gun out oh I
would have been shooting up a storm my
expert analysis tells me that someone
had died here and that the noises should
be wary of my boom banger
okay I was a bit you know caught off
guard because of the that not top-notch
graphics but I sometimes forget that it
doesn't need have a good graphics when
it's got a good atmosphere okay alright
game ok game is this grass versus a
horrible carpet oh oh okay you know I I
don't like why is there a naughty chair
who needs to be putting at me me I go a
naughty corner please thank you I want
to go in the naughty corner now if I
just stay here and I stare at the corner
I won't think about all the horrible
monstrosity that are lurking up behind
me and I definitely won't think about
all the monstrosity that are looking up
behind you
that was an inopportune time for the
music to cut up I did not do that that
was the game okay well I my boomstick um
I was just gonna look around my why is
this door already opened oh it's a
closet that that would be why ok nothing
here alright red ah much better choice
more stylist move 11 110 what did you
just say I don't even know what you just
said what I need to say to me oh no idea
whatever alright
I don't know what noises just came out
of my body but I don't think I've ever
made those noises before you
have eyes I hate you can I just shoot
you okay glad we took care that you are
horrifying I hate you if you sneak up
behind me I swear to God
okay whatever it's fine probably it's
right by me
good do you think that kind of stuff is
just okay to do huh
you think that I'm just gonna allow you
to do that kind of stuff to me no no I'm
sorry I did not know that that would
make me go outside I'm outside now
forever which is uh no is that a snowman
interesting art piece oh oh okay oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
all right fine that's a little weird but
not that weird so I guess uh oh you had
on the other side I see oh hi hello oh
wait a minute are you in the naughty
corner are you in timeout
what do I do about this hello I'm a
police officer I'm here to rescue you I
think
[Music]
uh yeah I'm collected three or four
evidence I don't even know what I
collected I don't even know what I did
what I win I guess oh my god
okay that was oh god the sirens and I'm
gonna get out of here real quick I I
cannot believe that that was as scary as
it was I can't fathom it that that
scared me that legitimately scared me I
don't know if it was just because of the
music the Krampus it's getting all these
cliches and one but that that scared me
ah I don't know why it just goes to show
I mean it's it's not poorly made I I do
want to say that I'm not criticizing the
game developer in any way but man you
would not expect that to be that scary
and yet it was so good alright anyway
moving on next up we have a game called
forgotten school which is a short
Japanese VHS Horrigan I didn't know that
was a category of games but what where
is everyone
I better hurry or I'll be late for class
two hundred meters okay you know that is
a good question where is everyone you'd
think that if I was late
well I guess if I'm late for class that
makes sense everyone would already be in
the school so my sorry butt needs to get
in that school that's definitely not
haunted in any way shape or form I know
this situation like the back of my hand
perfectly a normal day oh I am really
stupid I need to go to the stairs that
it's quite obviously pointing at okay I
am up primary class hello teach
I have to find the library for why do I
have to find the library first
I got taller oh that ain't right
well let me film that hate yourself
lifeless Oh loser dumb um I'm sorry okay
well this is an awfully pessimistic
there's an awfully pessimistic game here
but uh oh hi ghost oh yeah maybe it's
best not to look into the ethereal
nature of the universe beyond and uh
just how do I grab things I want that
but I can't have it
so tantalizingly close and yet so far
yeah maybe it's best not to peer into
the beyond because the beyond seems
really depressing no book I wonder if
this is the library oh the library seems
something something's rubbing me wrong
about this library of here huh very
concerning did I bring up my ethereal
camera from
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah okay who is going on oh well this
is awfully disturbing huh and now it's
normal and this Durbin
yeah yeah oh-ho-ho-ho hi oh wait no Hey
I don't want it well guys were putting
it away
huh hey how you doing
um that's weird and my dad is everyone
else dead
I don't know man I don't know what's
happening Oh moral of the story because
I mean yeah sure yeah if there's gonna
be a moral about this be kind rewind I'm
not sure what the hell happened I think
it was probably a game about bullying if
I had to guess and then a student ended
up committing suicide that's my guess as
to what this game is about ho k so this
next game I'm pretty sure this game is
not what it seems to be but I can't
confirm that it's a game about literally
doing your taxes and a headphone
recommendation because that's something
that you would need when you're just
doing your taxes so let's go let's do
our tack keep taxes what does that mean
oh I tossed okay alright easy enough
being bald is a choice someone till wid
that hose a lot of taxes I did seven
taxes I threw away eight things tax
returns Oh Oh Jimmy mock liar and a tiny
box Tim to cap it off there we go
alright next day I good job thanks thank
you
Wow oh wait that's not taxes is that
taxes that's not taxes I got tricked oh
shoot
okay well I'm screwing this up ah not
taxes not taxes no no no no taxes taxes
no no no aah
I might have goofed out a bit oh no way
that's a big negative number
I might've goofed it okay I'll give me a
big ol mark blah tiny back stim bad job
I I'm aware I'm aware whoa
that's a nice check can I keep that that
looks good
at toss it oh wait IRS important that's
not taxes maybe I should keep the checks
am i doing it wrong with the yes I am
unsure if those things are actually
taxes or not I am doing very poorly in
this excursion
I did eight taxes at least I'm in the
posse
a big ol em tiny tiny box Tim's has
never looked better doing it ah thank
you thank you
oh it's dark I don't know why it's dark
what
what the hell is that what the hell do
you guys hear that
well this is this is a depressing amount
of nothing all right uh okay did that I
did zero taxes I threw away thirty five
pieces of junk okay just a big ol tiny
box Tim let's put that day there you go
he's a cute little biscuit whoa you did
taxes that's us Thank You tiny bags
superb I'm aware I'm aware I'm aware of
these things five okay
please help wait what did I say please
help please help please help oh okay I'm
really doing it guys I'm really do you
ever feel like you're being watched up
not often Oh way way that was important
wait why was that important my money
went down feeling trapped what what was
that what was that what was that wait a
minute what was that way what was that
what the hell was that what the hell was
that oh so what is with this goddamn
mind-numbing music is this intentional I
thought at first it was just like
something being like okay just a common
drone but I feel like this music is
eating away at my soul yes thank you yes
indeed that's a lot of coffees error are
you crazy
well you know not not often let's a
PayPal em now all right interesting
all right well
I will not listen to you voices in my
head telling me to stop don't even think
about it you think that you know me not
not true at all
nailed it tell you what I nailed that
what does it even matter we've been
through this
oh wait a minute hang on you might want
to stop what you're doing here
yeah let me think about things before
you just take action like this I'm not
in too many of sort of things I need I
need some time to think about it
thinking it over to Kampala bye-bye
I wasn't planning on leaving you here
you get a tiny box Tim right there and
you and tiny box Tim has a tinier box as
a friend look so you're not alone
anymore oh that is an interesting paper
that's definitely taxes taxes taxes I
know taxes when I see taxes I know taxes
just keep doing my tag just doing my
taxes here don't know what you guys are
doing I'm doing my taxes sure are a lot
of taxes to do today oh well penny saved
is a penny earned another dollar another
day
the only thing scape is death and taxes
okay I think I'm getting close to the
end oh hello
do you really want to go back oh um well
I mean like I guess I can't you're not
letting me really do I can't really mmm
I just I don't really wanna I don't want
to fight I want to make a fuss about
things but I can't
seems to not be allowing me to do
anything else okay how about I've got
I've got a hack around this I know how
to know how to deal with nerds okay
we're gonna build a nice line here okay
I'm gonna build another nice line here
oh yeah see I've beat you at your own
game have beat you at your own game
no hahaha Billy oh I didn't mean that
Oh
um yeah I'll keep that to the right the
pills the pills there bye-bye it
bye now now get out of here ha ha keep
that to the left okay I want to go back
left okay left left
oh now get that now stupid
advertisements all right to the right
yeah keep my laughing yeah get out of
here get out of here get out of here get
out of here Oh money yeah um is there
some kind of like offshoot of
presentable liberty where I'm just
perpetually spiraling down or have a
hole as I slowly erode what sanity half
I guess yeah I get that pills go back to
sleep keep that one it bills out here
wait what
[Music]
all right
Oh would you like to go back go back to
what I don't know what I'm going back to
I'm gonna go with no cuz I'm assuming I
want the truth
I do not do not want to go back
[Music]
okay um I guess that's the end of that
game uh I feel like I feel like I feel
like some new medic virus has wormed its
way into my brain and my subconscious
will be ruptured from the inside out but
hey pretty cool game I love surreal
things like this I love them I think
they're so cool I think there's so much
potential in doing experiences like this
and making these into games so really
well done well well good job good job
great maybe there's a secret that I
didn't find I don't know if you get like
a perfect game does it even matter
that's what they asked I don't know I
don't know what's happening so thanks
everybody for watching let me know what
you thought down in the comments below
and yeah does do your taxes do those
taxes I guess so that has been three
scary games thank you everybody so much
for watching that thing is still behind
you but I wouldn't worry about it too
much just don't turn around
if you want to see more of these there's
a link in the description and there's
suggested scary games over there and
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]